I just want you to know that Canada
voted on what I should wear tonight and
they picked my Ryan Gosling pants and I
just want to know what do you want to
say to Canada
about this vote
can I have my pants back
has anyone ever had pants with your face
on it have you yeah and how did Canada
sneak into my house
to steal my pants I know
I'm Canadian I swear I didn't stealing
you no I didn't go in your house I
wouldn't do that I would never Canada
did it
they voted
do you like the pants
they're mine I feel like yes those are
incredible thank you amazing those are
great thank you very much prepared it
all so well I worked hard on this
musical I don't know what you were on
top you could never figure out what to
put them
but here we are yeah here we are okay
congratulations on this movie I just
want to know when when you were offered
the movie
did you have a family conference and be
like am I can do you think he's can Mom
Dad am I Ken who did you consult with
or did you just feel the Kenner G in
your boat like such a no-brainer to me
sorry Interruption no
but I always knew it was there wow yeah
but it's beautiful thanks
well she's my original Barbie so did he
play Barbies with you as a kid were you
good at it's funny it's I was like that
one kid who never owned a Barbie I never
she was too busy being Barbie he thinks
he's got an explanation okay yeah but
she's doing all the things all the time
you know if you made a school safely and
then she was the president of that
school oh more meetings than classes
I was like this is just like my house
this is like life well then are you a
good Barbie dad like do you get down on
the floor can you role play because my
husband had a really hard time
role playing with the Barbies are you
good at that
her Barbie's
very complicated
backstories interrelationships
history
you got to know it all because if you
don't because if you kind of like are
playing with you that are estranged now
for some reason maybe they had a fight
it's like just someone wore the pants
they don't even talk you know okay and
by the way he works at a grocery store
okay he's not a fireman get out of here
get out okay you gotta know last what is
the most Canadian thing about Ken
is it his eyes it is his soul like what
is what is it do you think it's just a
very strong energy in Canada and I'm not
sure we know why there's studies being
done
you almost pulled that off
there's a link between
um Tim Hortons Timbits and Polka Dot
Door oh oh yeah yeah okay there's some
connection there we're not sure all
right but we're looking for funding
fantastic life in plastic it's
oh my gosh Ryan drastic
and that's the end of the story everyone
looks so good well it's for you this is
not for you no no that's not what this
is that's not what this is what what I
think what I think is happening is this
movie
is inspiring everyone to just step into
their light to become their best
brightest versions of themselves and
that's what we're seeing is that
everyone is just like embracing their
inner Barbie their inner Ken and it's
just it's amazing to witness I'm looking
so looking at everyone and they just
look everyone looks great so my question
to you is what is the most Canadian
thing about Ken
um the most Canadian thing about Ken
um let's see it's Pride but I know that
Margot I don't know that there's two is
he polite is it the way he stands is it
the way he loves like what do you think
it is
uh I think I think to call Ken's polite
and to call them Canadian would be
giving kids too much credit and Ken's
don't start the movie in a particularly
empowered place but maybe they get there
near the end maybe they've become a
little bit more Canadian at the end
where they realize you know you know
here's what I say the most Canadian the
most Canadian thing about tents is that
they celebrate each other's differences
they don't provide in their
multiculturalism yeah and they're a very
accepting group of people for the most
part so what was more difficult playing
an action hero or prepping to have your
body out for the Barbie movie
I would say each has comes with its own
specific set of challenges and
um you know Barbie being being 10 or
transforming and the canvas is no
different obviously the waxing is a big
okay let's talk about that can we
actually like did you did you fully wax
like all the things
no that's not what I meant that is not
I'm gonna need another question I think
I'm gonna back it up and I'm gonna say
did you wax your legs did you ask your
armpits and what all of all of the parts
that would make I'm just looking at your
leg I'm senior well we're gonna explain
this
here's the reason
okay I looked for simu pants okay and I
couldn't find them but I am coming to
your basketball game next week oh wow
and when I come I'm gonna have some
pants
okay I just want you to know
okay I don't know how to feel I mean
I mean the pants look great he looks
great in the pants
back to your waxing uh it was okay you
did all right
yeah yeah it was good it was the
predominantly the legs there's really
any any part of the body that would show
yeah and so so that answers your other
question too but um
um yeah I know it's I have a newfound
appreciation for anyone that undergoes
that on like a endures that on a regular
semi-regular basis because that's that's
serious that's amazing if you could pick
another Canadian to be a Ken who'd you
pick oh that's a great question
um
probably Ryan Reynolds let's get let's
get the lions in dueling Ryan
I like that
thank you for your time you're the best
I'll see you at the basketball game I'll
have my pants on